[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
I'm a test engineer for Tesla my name is
JD price and we're out here in New
Zealand working on model wide track mode
a new development for the model y
performance package so this is full
oversteer all your Drifter guys are
going to love this kind of setting
because as soon as you just tip out you
can just rotate the car around and do
some pretty wild Maneuvers
[Music]
we're here with all of our various
platforms working on low mu winter test
improvements every car that you see has
a Raj on it right now so these are all
Tesla cars moving doing different
Maneuvers out and back things in green
mean we have it it's a good way to keep
track of people it's pretty Relentless
out here with uh with the visibility and
the constant Dynamic weather where else
you're going to find snow in July and
August it's crazy it's confusing for the
body and it's always been that way I
think there's a saying the customer is
going to do it so we have to do it first
you're walking the line between stable
and unstable Tesla's had some of the
best safety scores in the game stuff
like this has been big reason for that
it's super cool to talk to people in
California send that update halfway
across the world you go on top of a
mountain test their update that's
something that I've never experienced
before we go all over to test the
vehicles to the extreme so that no
matter where the customer takes the car
the vehicles can be stable we're almost
always on a Proving Ground testing new
software and we run this thousands of
times per software release we do
everything from driving the car writing
the code doing the collaboration that
feedback loop is super quick it's cool
to think
[Music]
the day in New Zealand starts at 5am
wake up go go go as soon as you get here
we usually here from like seven to seven
I will drive back look at data prepare
builds for the next day and hopefully
grab some dinner when you come this far
kind of becomes a family everyone loves
it like we're doing this because we
really want to you know it takes a
certain personality obviously fun but
also very important the work that we're
doing here but it puts a smile on your
face every single day no matter how many
weeks you're working here
[Music]
foreign